so it is christmas time is it
sea world it is and um
christmas time is well there's a couple
things that are that are going on with
christmas but
meeting santa has been a lot different
for kids this year i mean
obviously uh because of covet as a
matter of fact
i think it was the dallas writer wrote
an article about how meeting santa now
uh kids understand that you know by
covet and that's
why they have to meet santa behind the
glass like it's in prison
um as a matter of fact i believe
i have the article here here it is
i can't pull it up here because i've run
out of like you know the free
views i'm paying those people yeah uh
and
okay uh
okay i still can't i i also have to pay
for that but look my point is
the article was yeah somebody did that
work around too many times
the article is this um buy a new phone
basic just
every time you want to do free articles
uh
did you take a picture with santa now
with the kids he can't sit on their lap
anymore anything like that
um one of the places they have like a
lot of places have like the glass up
like you're visiting a prisoner and how
does this affect like all these
small santas like that's got to be it
must hurt them so
then you have places like this where
apparently you have to sit across a
conference table
with santa and negotiate with it and
negotiate with you you got to write down
what you want on a little piece of paper
and then slide it across the table so
um i believe this kid was asking this
santa for a nerf gun
let's see what happened okay he's the
other one that sent this to me so
what do you want for christmas um
ask what do you want for christmas the
mom's filming it as moms do
you know
[Music]
what
so the kid said i want a nerf gun i know
it's hard to hear what he's saying
he said i want a nerf gun okay
and what no no before you keep hitting
play now what's the appropriate response
to that
well if you're if if you're if you're a
good boy
we'll see what santa can do or you're
not a good santa
or the appropriate response to that
would be
you look at the mom because the mom
might not want to get have a nerf gun
not because of the gun thing but because
you know i ain't [ __ ] shooting people
bringing stuff in the house i get it
uh what would the appropriate prompts be
for you the appropriate response is
always yes it's not a mall santa's job
to even worry about the parent you bring
a keg
what do you want for christmas i don't
know why it's the announcer from snl
saying that's weird
and then um pete davidson exactly
i don't know why don pardo is
moonlighting as a mall saying he's dead
but and then the gay kid goes i want a
nerf gun and you go oh
we'll see what we can do for you kiddo
merry christmas
ho ho ho and that's it and you move on
that's it it's it's it's simple that's
all it is
to santa's i we used to go to when i was
a kid they always kept it vague
but hopeful okay of course i'll remember
that they'll say something like
i'll remember that and you go okay so
it's not a commitment
but it's like hey i'm i heard what
you're saying right up here i'm not
going to forget i'm santa
and that's the end of it but this what
did this guy did did he do that didn't
he here's what he did
he said you don't know
i want a nerf gun is what the kid said
it's hard to hear
what
[Music]
no nope no guns no guns
no guns by the way i've been 37 years on
this planet
you and i have both seen some wild [ __ ]
yeah particularly in the last four years
of course
this is the first time in my entire life
i've ever heard santa say no to a child
it's
it's like we preach like we've we've
seen some wild [ __ ]
and we keep going it can't get any
crazier but this
might be kind of high on the list of
wild [ __ ] i've seen like
you show me a couple of teenagers
fighting in a mall and i'm like yeah
whatever santa literally went no he said
no we said no
santa royce santa claus said no
and yes why is santa's voice is santa
you noticed that voice xanax got nerfed
and then the mom repeated no no no nerf
gun nerf gun
so the mom's trying to so at this point
look is what i'm doing right i'm already
santa's wrong
but let's say we're giving santa the
benefit of the doubt okay
i really want to do this the benefit of
the doubt which is like well he's saying
no because maybe he thinks the mom
doesn't want the
whether you agree with it or not
whatever but then the mom goes no no
it's a nerf gun
trying to get trying to feel like crazy
it's okay it's fun it's cool
the mom probably already got him a nerf
gun you know
pretty short some kid's probably been
talking if i was that mom
i'd still get him a few things from
santa i put my name on that [ __ ] box
the nerf gun
and when you open that up oh i was
saying this stuff's cool whatever and
then open up mine boom nerf gun and i go
look santa's a friend i don't know what
his problem is but
i heard you kid i got you hey hey who's
your mom
[ __ ] santa
nope not even a nerf gun look at the kid
look at the kid look at his mom
like but you said if i was a good boy
you know it's bad i'm sorry you know i'm
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] this guy it's so bad when a
seven-year-old
kid looks at his mom and goes is this
serious is he being real right now
like again i'm still blown away by the
fact
we're watching santa say no to a child
right like that's there are some times
we've been saying this for years on this
show there are times
where people deserve to be punched in
the face
for politics right i would believe this
is one of those times right
this is this is again this is we i've
been talking about this for years
even when i even when i'm like not in
the christmas spirit right
even when you're not in the christmas
spirit there's kids around and [ __ ]
right you put on a good fit
you [ __ ] you pretend right because
you don't want
your misery and your cynicism to
transfer to those children
they've only got a limited amount of
time to enjoy
the wonder of not knowing that the world
is actually a shitty place and that life
is terrible
let them have it so i i get like
violently angry at people like this at
christmas time
because look i've had a very imperfect
life
and i'm still very [ __ ] up human being
but there are some times where you go
hey
knock it the [ __ ] off dude it's the mo
it's kids bro like
she's supposed to be [ __ ] singing
songs and elves and you're supposed to
just
death what are you doing and this kid
all these kids years have already been
[ __ ] because of the remote learning
and they can't play sports and
like you know what i mean like this is
already got to be shitty for a kid you
know
and and and to be to go there finally
your mom takes you to [ __ ] santa you
have to wear stupid
mask and all this dumb [ __ ] and i have
this [ __ ] guy that only works [ __ ]
one month out of the year to tell you no
but you know what bothers me
this video it's not just 23 seconds long
it's three minutes long and this isn't
good this is where it's gonna get you're
gonna get very
this is why you're gonna feel my anger
and you're gonna want to get violent all
right all right here we go
now if your dad wants to get it for you
that's fine but i can't bring it to you
but what else would you like
lots of other toys my dad died defending
your freedoms in afghanistan
mommy says daddy went to heaven help
making sure that mall santa's like you
could work every day of the week
you're a muslim how old's the kid oh
he's got to be seven or eight
someone i'm just i'm out the chat will
figure it out but yeah he's he's a young
kid though he's not
older than eight years old right um you
don't
do it it's this there's a time and a
place dude he's a four-year-old
the only thing you tell him is were you
a good boy this year all right we'll do
what we can for you
merry christmas that's it this isn't
about you
it's not about your views on guns it's
not about
politics it's not about buying or trump
if anybody
inserts politics while talking to a
four-year-old about a nerf gun
as santa claus you are a [ __ ]
sociopath you're a sick person for doing
that
legos bicycles there's cars and trucks
what do you think
what do you think
it's okay if you're dead i hope she sues
this mall
oh wow oh he balls he balls crying
the rest of this video is this kid
crying which is
oh this makes me mad dude
[Music]
it's okay if you're dead
[Music]
this dude needs to be [ __ ] fired and
never
had to be a santa he was he was fired
fired him
cuz the mall doesn't want anything to do
with this [ __ ] the mall just wants you
to go yeah kid no kid cool
merry christmas kid that's it
how do you [ __ ] this job up this is the
easiest gig in the world right
how do you [ __ ] this job up
how do you [ __ ] this job up why would
you the easiest gig in the world
you put on a [ __ ] santa outfit and
you just be
friendly to kids for a couple of hours
at the mall it's
really not a difficult job
you just wear a santa sat suit and you
yes
children to death until you get your
[ __ ] paycheck it's
not hard i don't get how this how do you
[ __ ]
this up
[Music]
you'll still get it
and then like and now you're also
[ __ ] this whole thing up right
because now
you're also [ __ ] this kid up because
now this kid is
he's crying and now the mom's going
don't worry we're going to get it for
you anyway so now
it's you're putting the mom in an
awkward spot where now she's reinforcing
bad behavior
this guy sucks man this guy like i don't
do this guy oh my god dude this guy
needs an ass whooping
this dude needs an ass whooping more
than anyone i've seen this year and that
says a lot
i can't think of a worse human being
right now am i am i off base with this
this gets a piece of [ __ ] the kid
i'm sorry this santa's a piece of [ __ ]
it's like what is the case
i apologize this santa's a piece of
shirt what did the four-year-old do
piece of [ __ ] trying to shoot people man
i'm telling you right now you know what
i'm a little violent [ __ ] i'm with santa
why would he need a gun anyway you know
the police will protect him
it was so funny because royce you could
tell he's trying to read something at
the same time
i was i i'm just i was i'm sorry i was
trying to figure out more about what
happened i apologize
this is a piece of [ __ ] i think you mean
santa [ __ ] you know what [ __ ] this kid
honestly put the kid too in the middle
you know
everybody dare you who still goes to
mall santa has to [ __ ] make toys for
everybody he's not gonna make you a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] gun yeah seriously
oh i'm gonna go to the mall because i'm
too cheap to buy the tyson fight so it's
the freeway watching black people fight
each other
no but joking is like this santa's a
piece of [ __ ] i mean
now this poor kid's gonna cry all day
and he's a kid man you know
it just i i
i'm telling you man this is one of those
things if i was walking
walking later outside and the santa was
just getting
jumped by four people viciously
normally you'd go hey hey hey all right
he's had enough
i would just light a cigarette and stand
there and be like this is hilarious
yeah good point what are you doing what
are you a literal child crying about
this
beating them throwing garbage cans on
them just wailing on them in a back
alley and i just stand there and go this
is awesome
and then when one of the guys goes hey
man you want to film this [ __ ] i'll go
no i want you guys to get away with this
please just keep beating them up all
this kid did was ask for a nerf gun
by the way this always happens when
these things happen i think it's one of
my favorite things in the world
honestly one hundred percent staged
how how was this this kid is an actor
now
well no so this was staged implying that
the santa who by the way just lost his
job when he only gets
to work and once a year was in on it
right so this santa was in on it
and made himself one of the most hated
people in the country
for what purpose it's that's the way it
always goes
everything is fake everything is staged
no i believe that if you've ever
been to a mall parents are always
filming their kids talking to santa
that's like the thing you do now right
somebody in the chat has a good theory
the mom should have pointed and said
this isn't the real santa
that would have been the best own ever
that's that's actually smart if i could
think if i would have thought of that
if that was my kid and they did that go
up and rip his beard off
and go this is a fake santa all along
and be like that's what you get you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
just walk out don't worry kiddo it's not
even a real sound we're going to take
you to real santa next week
just go to another santa and be like
i'll get you a nerf gun and you're like
thanks bro alex jones walks in pulls his
beard down
you're not even the real santa you know
these globalists are out here they're uh
they're trying to infiltrate all of our
organizations and all of our
institutions and as you can see here
uh even santa claus isn't safe if
they're out here they're pretending to
be santa claus they're interdimensional
and they're trying to touch the kids and
they can't even give him
a nerf gun he says [ __ ] raging about
it
i have a stack of letters to santa right
here it's on his desk he's
riding around in his black truck firing
a nerf gun
out of the top of the truck just firing
nerf darts at people
[Laughter]
santa yeah he really should just do
santa yep
alex jones is santa would be great alex
jones as santa would have given this kid
a real ar
learn how to use it kid you're gonna
have to learn sometime
because they're gonna cut listen to me
kid see alex jones would be
[ __ ] up for a santa but in a
completely different direction
you know the kid would be like i want a
nerf gun and be like i'm gonna tell you
what i'm gonna do kid i'm gonna get you
an ar-15
let me get your entire case ammo listen
here they're gonna come for you they're
gonna come for your mother someday
they're going to come for your little
sister
they're coming for you all these
globalist charcoms
are coming for you and the kid starts
crying anyway i'm giving you a real gun
kid
cause that's what you need right now i
gave rex his first gun when he was four
he'd walk around chewing on the thing i
tell him stop rex
that's a that's a tool that's a machine
of death that's a tool to
globalists oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] now i'm thinking about alex
jones just being santa be amazing
rex was three years old i bought him his
first ksg his first caltech ksg shotgun
eight rounds automatic boom you're like
what
oh [ __ ] when rex turned 11 years old i
bought him a case of grenades
[Laughter]
took him out to kill squirrels